I I jerked off one time uh in an alley
next to a dumpster
whoa why did you do that
[Music]
in important news that we of course have
to share 15
000 ukrainians decide to have a mass
orgy if Russia deploys nuclear weapons
fifteen thousand is with ten thousand is
that a threat to the nuclear weapons it
should be like the missiles like I'm not
gonna shoot
[Laughter]
a poll went down more than 15 000 people
have confirmed participation in a sex
party on a hill if Putin decides to
press the red button with participants
even indicating whether they prefer anal
or oral sex
is it because Putin really doesn't like
that or because I don't see the logical
how that stops uh I don't think they're
trying to stop it it's just like hey the
world's gonna end let's just blow each
other it's like yeah but if it doesn't
know everybody has AIDS now it's not age
bro
it's we don't know and look I'll say
this it's a pull so that means 15 000
people they can click yes but in reality
it'll be like 200 people like a Facebook
event yeah like you're not all gonna go
not everyone's gonna storm the [ __ ]
area or if a nuke actually gets pressed
people aren't necessarily going to be
able to get it up you know what I mean
they might just be freaking out just be
depressed and thinking about life
imagine it's just one person who shows
up to this event oh that's a lonely guy
dude oh my God because it's going to be
15 000 people who said yes only one
showed up also probably most of the
people that said yes
Pride dudes that's true yeah probably 14
000 dudes yeah yeah they're like oh dude
there's gonna be so many chicks here 14
000 gay dudes then we're cooking now
it's gonna be a real orgy there's lots
of gays in Russia or Ukraine or Ukraine
wow both have a deficit huh yeah a
deficit is what we call it you know that
could probably be true that's fifteen
thousand people that that say yes and
also have to go through with it because
like most things of that nature it's
hard to uh commit once you're in the
moment yeah you mean get erect yeah or I
mean just in general like to be like I
don't think I can do this now you know
everyone's like the world's ending
we have time it's like right when you
press it everybody goes Rockets up oh I
feel like I feel like Putin would just
prank everyone into being like I push
the button better get to [ __ ]
that's on brand with food too yeah
that's not Brit that would be the
sickest War play yeah it's a good troll
huh but he you know he doesn't have a
sense of humor you ever be intrigued in
entering some sort of orgy I I would uh
I would like to watch it first as a
spectator yeah in the center or like
from the side oh no like power forward I
would love to see it like up close yeah
and I would like to have a conversation
the guy's head is right here and I go
hello what's your name and then look at
that no I would like to be mic'd up and
you'd be mine because it's nice I'd
never get to see it you know I would
like to go close but and the first thing
you want to do is go up to the guy this
close
maybe she feels uncomfortable can they
see you or is it like a two-way no they
can see me I go hey I'm here you think
that would ruin the vibe of the origin
um no I don't think so because
everybody's already having sex do I mean
they're like horny they're like horny
but I'm not gonna be horny they all stop
when you enter the room that's a great
in between yeah you don't think that
what makes you horny the sound
everything's good stuff just quiet yeah
you don't think that'll make your own
you don't think seem to be love sex will
make you horny or too no dude because
there's too many things going on like
one one-on-one is already difficult yeah
you know to have a nice one do you know
what I mean yeah but to have two is like
so much because now it's like oh [ __ ]
okay okay YouTube that's an orgy no
that's a oh I'm what I mean is threesome
is already difficult but then now I
gotta [ __ ] 55 people this guy gets it
bro he's scaling it he gets it thank you
but also too it's like I don't think
I'll say this we're probably talking
from the lens of someone that has never
did orgies ever been close to being an
orgy so obviously we're we're thinking
like oh also age mayor no way it could
be logistically yeah logistically a
nightmare but have any of you guys ever
been CL what's the closest you've ever
been to like an orgy situation is there
anything yeah what do you think Anthony
yeah he's been to Europe the most times
I looked over here to Ryan to be polite
and I was waiting
no thank you I see that I was I was
Wi-Fi router in your gaze this way
I'm signaling with Ryan yeah no I got
you so like what's as close as you've
been Anthony Lee
you're Colleen
Bart it's your question the BART next
time
I haven't been [ __ ] close Joe no
[ __ ] way so more than 15 000 have
already registered on telegram for the
sex party the mass orgy will take place
on a hill outside the city where the
participants would be asked to decorate
their hands with colored Stripes
symbolizing their sexual interests if
you are considering participating three
stripes are for anal sex lovers and four
stripes are for oral sex lovers I wonder
why they skipped one and two maybe
that's a gift I also wonder why we just
skipped the question entirely yeah yeah
everyone looked at me and went okay next
you can tell your story now I think yeah
who's deflecting now yeah that story is
uh three straps for anal sex lovers four
stripes for oral sex livers but also is
on a hill yeah like how do you have your
how can you get your dick
nightmare dude okay
the top you're like oh
yeah but what if the hell is has like a
little it's rounded up at the top okay
then that's nice man
that's what I did was like yo this hill
doesn't have a top
this is vertical yeah it doesn't have to
be like this
that's very true that's a Mesa Mesa you
know also how many times have you guys
had a boner in the on the outside or huh
yeah on the outside no I mean in the
wild yeah yeah I mean like outside where
there's trees and birds and yeah that's
true in the wild it's hard to get boners
at that time you've never been camping
before yeah but not on the outside that
might be my penis can't get hard on the
outside where there's like
I can't hear and also have a have a hard
on do you know what I mean you hear
Google it's time to go
it's time to tuck your penis away
yeah what do you mean human nature kicks
in have you had I know maybe that's why
some people like to have outside
Outdoors oh sex because it's exciting
they're like maybe a bear is gonna eat
my dick those are the real it's daring I
don't I don't think people are like
maybe
a mosquito yeah a bear or a mosquito
yeah same there's mosquitoes in the city
too guaranteed yeah but not on the
outside mostly oh my I'm not not on it
they're only indoors
yeah they've already started dude
I'm on the outside
have you ever had sex on the outside
yeah and like it uh but it was in like a
college thing oh I got the a a
just at like uh how like a stairwell oh
cool like a hallway thing is that
considered Outdoors though that's
indoors that's what I'm saying the
mosquitoes not there there's no bears
but I think were you asking if you've
had sex Outdoors without your ass is
that what you're asking yeah oh no not
Outdoors no Outdoors oh no I lied
there's behind the bush on the go one
time oh wow behind the bush on a car
yeah in the trunk in the truck on your
trunk or on the trunk hard to follow you
open the trunk and then there's like a
little thing there oh wow your
experience no
just one time how would you rate that
experience
um
would you do drunk
drunk no because it's like difficult
yeah yeah but but logistic wise but
memorable as [ __ ] though right yeah I
think that's the the point sometimes you
do things because it's more unique and
memorable because let's say you have
great sex on your bed all the time you
do like a thousand times you might not
remember 600 to 800 you know what I mean
you go you go to a truck bed one time
but behind a bush even if it's okay yeah
but you'll always remember that right
it's the art of perspective I I jerked
off one time uh in an alley next to a
dumpster
that's not really what a homeowner would
do
were you
I'm gonna throw it out there were you
homeless at the time by chance does the
car count no
um no I was not but uh oh why did you go
buy a dumpster I
I was just drunk yeah you just gotta get
one out yeah it's just super drunk and
horny in the uh that's pretty cool yeah
don't lick your lips like that and stick
your tongue out what he's right
did anyone else catch that it was a
little slurp and then you're like
reminiscing
you saw you go back yeah I was like
don't do that man what you're in The
Matrix for a second oh you know what it
is it's so embarrassing I think I think
it was because me and my friend dude
look at that bicep vein coming out yeah
[Laughter]
I think because I went to like we went
clubbing I think and then um we were
like okay we're gonna go find women and
then
um we didn't find women
I'm sorry
[Laughter]
there it is wait so that's how it
happened you just didn't find women yeah
it was me and my Korean friend or we
went and then I was like oh man that's
sad and then um I just I I don't know if
I had material but I just uh I was like
oh there's a
oh maybe I thought was close or
something or like we made out maybe and
then I was like oh man I but I didn't
close yeah yeah blue balls yeah so you
need it to finish
so you just had to finish what made you
finish in the alley that's what I'm
saying I'm thinking about that too yeah
I was just like oh [ __ ] it right now
maybe I don't know maybe I'll just super
horny probably yeah you were boned up
you gotta get rid of that bone you know
yeah now I'm embarrassed now why are you
embarrassed at least you got to make out
with somebody that's pretty cool yeah
and now that you've told the story on
here eventually the person with the nest
cam is going to see this and be able to
show the footage
you're that guy the alley guy yeah
I'm sorry we deviated no no no I don't
apologize we still have time if you want
to tell your uh story no you have an
orange store you wanted to share where
everybody wants everybody
laughs
[Music]